I'm Francesca and this is an explainer
on al-shabaab who are they and how did
they become a major force in Somalia
first the basics al-shabaab is a
militant group with some 5,000 fighters
it controls large parts of Somalia and
has been linked to al-qaeda al-shabaab
subscribes to a strict interpretation of
Islam and wants Somalia to be ruled
under its version of Sharia law the
group has claimed responsibility for
dozens of major attacks within the
country and beyond his borders including
the 2013 mall attack in Nairobi Kenya
which killed at least 67 people and the
2010 attack in Kampala Uganda which
killed at least 74
but that doesn't really explain who
al-shabaab is to do that we have to talk
more about Somalia ever since Somalia's
government was overthrown more than two
decades ago the country has been in
turmoil in the chaos clans led by
warlords carved up their own territories
but clans in the capital Mogadishu had a
common denominator Islamic Courts each
clan had its own court and eventually
these courts joined forces this union of
Islamic Courts had a militant armed
al-shabaab the exact origins of
al-shabaab are hard to pinpoint but it
is known that many of its Somali members
fought in Afghanistan against the Soviet
Union and later the u.s. al-shabaab
gained a lot of Somali support in its
early years Mohammed addo a reporter for
al-jazeera
told us why they fought the wall of Swat
and if I divided Somalia into systems
and managed to remove them from power
really weaken the influence
so increasingly people started you know
seeing them as saviors and they warned a
lot of accolades young men in particular
respondents al-shabaab which means the
youth in Arabic well you can imagine a
country where there's been looks like so
for many young men who joined the runs
of al-shabaab to fight al-shabaab and
other militias the international
community back to transitional federal
government or TFG Ethiopia invaded
Somalia in 2006 to support the TFG but
that backfired and many Somalis threw
their support behind al-shabaab
presenting the incursion of a
traditional rival
around this time al-shabaab broke from
the Islamic Courts Union waging its own
insurgency in response western-backed
forces from Uganda and Burundi as well
as Kenya all joined the fight against
al-shabaab
on Somali soil in the last two years
these forces have managed to reduce
al-shabaab territory and Somali support
for the group is at an all-time low
especially because of its hardline
tactics meanwhile al-shabaab continues
to carry out suicide attacks and
bombings both inside and outside the
country and that's it for this explain
Iran al-shabaab thanks for watching